from a bird's head to a dinosaur's tail
remarkable discoveries have emerged from
amber mines in northern Myanmar
encapsulating the teeming flora and
fauna of an ancient forest 99 million
years in the past
back then massive trees with trunks
upwards of a metre in diameter
used resin in response to threats like
storms and insect swarms and at the same
time capturing myriad kinds of ancient
life but the way these astounding
Burmese amber fossils make their way to
scientists hands poses an ethical
quandary the region their mind from in
Myanmar is rife with conflict most of
them is not controlled by the mainmast
and state governments so it's controlled
by the ki a catch in Independence and in
so these soldiers control this air and
collect texts from the - about two
hundred thousand people who are in the
Maya area in 2014
Ruby mines in the South dried up driving
new miners north - amber mines they
write the memo the embolize say so low
heck we bring high technology go deeper
and likkle deeper they took there from
the 10 meters 20 meters goes through to
100 meters so she change a lot
as these miners dug deeper more and more
impressive specimens emerged as of 2019
over a thousand new species have been
described most countries have laws to
keep fossils in their borders
but as Burmese amber fossils are
considered to be gemstones they can be
exported a majority of the amber is
smuggled into China and sold in tank
Chong a market in the Yunnan Province
here middlemen Hawk fossils to wealthy
collectors as well as scientists Shing
Lida specializes in vertebrate
paleontology and frequents the amber
market in pursuit of the next
groundbreaking specimen I love this part
I love this part
it make me not like scientist made me
like job dealer because every time I go
there I need to bring cash Smalling says
to meet you but anything with about the
Buddha breast that feathers Wow so
expensive one of Kings most amazing
discoveries was purchased at a
surprisingly low price my guys found
this specimen is like a small exercise
and he looks like a very beautiful print
to small head inside and I used to love
to see this specimen at the first kind
of say oh my goodness feda is not
praying and this Fed is very very based
in the evolution trips to the base
mythology only to possibility wines from
very very old cupboard or from Dennis
hotel so I some specimen to my quarry he
put in the micro City before it is 8 or
9 code of vertebrates
hundreds of famous so this first time
the people can see the real dinosaur the
fresh on my face and this pen December's
pictures everywhere when I go to the
market I cannot get anything because
they always could be very high price to
perceive me this
ten pounds price as the sellers have
realized the value of certain specimens
acquiring them for scientific studies
becomes more expensive this introduces
an ethical issue around the mixed nature
of commercial sales and scientific
research hwangbo a researcher at the
Nanjing Institute of geology and
paleontology studies Burmese fossils to
illuminate the behavior and ecology of
the forests insects the information
emperor and their lot all other special
end such as unique land this and had a
very long haul is very different of
wrong or accident and and we can use the
mandible and the haunt who can catch
debris we have one a sound and preserved
together all they are workers so that
means we have creating social
eighty-four an even clearer picture of
the past Wong has been able to determine
the color of some ancient moths through
looking at nano structures that refract
light on the surface of wings we use
some new technology such as a copper
core microscope we can see the detailed
structure the Nano structure about the
wind skills and fits this nano structure
within calculate the structure color it
looks like some coating and yellow color
in the future Wong hopes to understand
the early days of parasites like fleas
ticks and mites for the fossil record we
have news early to fleet it up around
middle Jurassic it's about a 150 many
years ago but they are primitive and
they are quite different brother
accidentally because they lived in the
host and so they are really pretty of
the amber but maybe in the near future
we can find that despite the promises of
Jurassic Park extracting blood from
these ancient parasites is almost
impossible but proteins may be fee
the blood is just degraded and icky and
butter we can get maybe in the future we
can get some protein if we know some
protein we can get maybe some the
sequence or of course it's the ejecta
fragment but it's the process step up or
get some molecular evidence from the 40s
some of Wong's research has involved
collaboration with a private collector
Xie Feng Wan who has loaned many of his
specimens to scientists we are good
friends and we just meet on his website
because he had a webshop lucky B then he
showed me a lot Oh were we
well crystal ampere but this ampere are
on sale amber yeah he said we can study
them and they agreed to earth Wang and
Xie recently collaborated on a paper
describing the first ammonite an extinct
group of marine mollusks in amber before
the discovery of em knives we know
nothing about the permit tampering for
with the environment also now we have
the m-net so we have a very robust
evidence that the forest grew all near
the coast I'm not either
very important index for Co fault
teaching it's also probe provided robust
evidence that this Emperor is the middle
Cretaceous in order for these findings
to be published in scientific journals
most require that the fossils are easily
accessible to other researchers who want
to test conclusions or extend the work
it's not give me personal creation evil
scientist so a joy it was my friend with
beware of Museum Xie also plans to build
a museum to house his collection in
Shanghai currently few new specimens are
coming to the market as in June of 2017
myanmar launched a military offensive
that took over the mining area most
amber mining has ceased since then still
some researchers like Shing Lida are
hopeful that other extraordinary
specimens are yet to be unearthed we
have some very nice leader extinct and
she dies big eyes watching you
so even you can fall dinosaur hold on a
skull in him but then watching even if
the mines reopen larger questions remain
about the ethics of purchasing amber
from a war-torn country and what role
science should be playing
you